Cold War killing
machines and lethal nuclear
weapons
abandoned under our
oceans the thought that these doomsday
weapons lie down there in the depths is
frightening the terrifying reality has
been
hidden the keys to the truth of the Cold
War lost under icy waters for over half
a
century imagine if we could empty the
oceans letting the water drain away to
reveal the secrets of the
seafloor now we
can using accurate
data and astonishing
technology to bring light once again
to a lost
world how did the cold Wars most
advanced submarine end up shattered on
the sea Flor a giant hand had just
crushed it how close does America come
to accidentally nuking Europe there was
this terrible
explosion big ball of flame and who
stole parts of a secret Soviet submarine
[Music]
October
1962 the United States and the Soviet
Union hit crisis point this is a red
alert
repeat Moscow installs nuclear missiles
in Cuba
President Kennedy issues an
ultimatum withdraw the missiles or it's
War a full retaliatory response upon the
Soviet Union
31,000 nuclear devices if it starts the
world would go up and smoke that's
it
crazy the Soviets back off
but the world remains just one mistake
away from nuclear
[Music]
apocalypse many flash points are hidden
from view shrouded in
[Music]
secrecy now we can reveal just how close
we came to
[Music]
disaster
in the waters of Northern
California a mysterious wreck could
reveal the truth about top secret
experiments at the dawn of the Cold
[Music]
War a giant object has been detected
under these
Waters Maritime archaeologist Dr James
Delgado wants to know more
more mapping the seabed outside the
Golden Gate they found a big Target a
very big Target was it a ship was it
something more what brought this here
why is it on the
bottom James hopes the new fine could
solve a cold war
mystery the location of a ship lost for
over 60
years USS Independence
a giant aircraft
carrier Imagine The Wreck of an aircraft
carrier as big as this sitting on the
bottom just off the coast of San
Francisco unrevealed for so many years
it's powerful it's
compelling he sets out to explore the
site with his
team
sending a remotely operated vehicle or
ROV 2600 ft
down a submerged
Beast you got to go a little further
brother a little more to the
left this is an area where we would have
had the name painted
there's the E
Independence you can see it NC e yes
yes this carrier is a hero of the second
world
war it battled to recapture Pacific
Islands from the
Japanese it survived all
that but it hasn't been seen for over
half a century
why is it now sitting in an unmarked
location at the bottom of these cool
Coastal
[Music]
[Applause]
Waters using Precision scan
data the waters roll
back to reveal a staggering
sight
a World War II
Colossus it looks almost new but on the
flight deck there's evidence of death
damage the surface torn buckled and
bent and one giant Corner punched in
completely on the hull strange
scars steel plate creased like tin
[Music]
foil on the control tower Eerie
details Japanese flags were were painted
on this killboard for every enemy unit
destroyed but now only white paint
remains now this should be painted in
different colors it should be red for
example but it's not here and that's not
age or
seawater what could have caused such
bizarre
damage James picks up on a trail of
evidence that leads him all the way to
the fiery dawn of the Cold War
[Music]
bikini atol July
1946 behind a ring of lowrise islands
nearly a 100 obsolete warships lie empty
and
abandoned one of them is the USS
Independence this remote Pacific Lagoon
is America's new Atomic test
Arena
it's less than a year since the first
ever atom bomb attacks on Japan ended
the second world
war and the US needs to know more about
what these terrifying new weapons can
do on July 25th at 8:35
a.m. the first ever test of an atom bomb
underwat
2 million tons of radioactive seawater
blasted into the
air the bomb punches out of the Lagoon
with a heated core hotter than the sun
shooting up through the heart of it
also an Airborne detonation as big as
the bomb at
Nagasaki a mile and a half from the
epicenter is the USS
Independence a blinding flash irradiates
her instantly vaporizing the red paint
on the
killboard the burst not only of light
but heat took away all the other colors
leaving only the white base coat then
blast waves rocked the
carrier shredding her flight
[Music]
deck and washboarding the steel around
her ho
this is all of those thousands of pounds
of air or water coming right up
alongside the ship and slamming into it
bending it denting it Rippling
it this is what an atomic bomb does to a
ship the many warships destroyed at
bikini carry a message this is the
future of
warfare with the Soviet Union working
around the clock on an atom bomb of its
own an arms race like no other will
dominate the decades to
[Music]
come the drained wreck of USS
Independence can tell us more of this
shadowy
confrontation but first we need to know
why does she lie not close to bikini but
California
hidden under the waters of Northern
California the wreck of the USS
Independence 4500 mil away from where
she was smashed by atomic blasts at
bikini
ATL how did she get
here and
why can our immense drained wreck
provide a clue
when you look all the damage brought by
the atomic bomb while Grievous for the
most part is above the waterline it
wasn't enough to sink the
ship the independence survives the
atomic
blasts but she's ravaged by
radiation it had been coded in
radioactive steam there's a near Panic
that the radiation levels have not
subsided much at
all in the summer of
1947 the independence is towed to
California James Delgado and his team
want to know why this was here for a
couple of years in they discover a link
to a top secret Naval Research facility
on the fringes of San
Francisco Hunters Point
[Music]
inside the high security port a
specialist team studies the radioactive
fallout on board
Independence their mission design a
defense against nuclear
weapons the key lessons underscored by
study of Independence is to just get
scarier to build more weapons to bring
more of them into play inure short
proliferation but a question
remains after almost 4 years at Hunter's
Point the US Navy scuttles
Independence and the wreck is nowhere
near where contemporary news stories
claim she
is we found it only 30 m offshore more
than 100 Mil miles away from where
reports said Independence had gone down
which stunned us and we began to think
why off the Waters of Northern
California James goes deep inside the
independence to look for
answers as the robot drops down I have
it zoom in again and again until finally
I see exactly what they're
hiding Now using Precision
data we can reveal what he finds
there in the hanger tucked behind a
Hellcat fighter
plane a stack of large sealed
barrels on one barrel a side panel has
rusted
away and when James inspects it up close
something catches his
eye
those are rubber
gloves looking at it everything from the
labs is getting packed in Barrel sealed
in concrete not only from Hunter's Point
but from the labs in and around the Bay
Area they wanted to put these away out
of the sight of prying eyes beyond the
reach of Soviet spies they were afraid
of
Espionage the US Navy decides to take no
no
chances whether Soviet spies are
operating in California or
not what better thing to do then with
your Atomic Secrets than to put them
inside this big carrier in a location
with all these nuclear secrets inomed
within
it
The Battered wreck of the independence
still lies off the California
coast a chilling reminder of the dawn of
the Cold
War in the years that follow the two
superpowers build huge nuclear
arsenals and sometimes accidents happen
the coast of
Almeria southern
Spain draining these Waters reveals a
shocking
sight a nuclear warhead more powerful
than a million tons of
TNT how does it get
here and how close is Spain to a nuclear
disaster Joe Ramirez is serving with
American forces here in the
1960s it's the height of the Cold War
and the US is flying nuclear arm patrols
over Europe Around the
Clock Operation Chrome Dome as it was
called B-52 bombers each carrying four
hydrogen bombs in Flight 24 hours a day
Chrome doome maintains a constant
nuclear threat against the Soviet
block but to keep the bombers Airborne
for as long as possible Crews must
refuel in
midair a delicate and dangerous
procedure on January 17th 1966 in the
Skies over
[Music]
Spain something Sparks an
explosion four bombs complete with
nuclear warheads hurdle towards the
ground two without their
parachutes the nuclear components are
unarmed but the conventional explosives
do detonate spreading radioactive
plutonium over a square
mile hundreds of American and Spanish
Personnel scour the
countryside and find three of the bombs
but that's
all we couldn't find the fourth
one the US military needs to locate
their lost nuke before it leaks
dangerous radiation or falls into the
hands of the
Soviets after more than a week of
searching the team still can't find the
bomb then Ramirez meets a local
fisherman he reports report seeing a
parachute fall into the sea on the day
of the
accident it hit me we're looking in the
wrong place we're looking for the bomb
on land this bomb may be in the
water but if the nuke is under the ocean
where is it and what condition is it
in in the last few years Spanish
oceanographers have mapped the
Mediterranean sea
Flor the bottom of the oceans is dark
but thanks to acoustical techniques we
can see all the particular features with
a incredible high resolution of the seab
Bel of the
oceans now with access to Dr Rivera's
data we can drain the Waters of southern
Spain exactly as it looked in
1966 and remove the sea from an American
nuclear
Calamity the Lost
nuke 2500 ft
down
teetering on a cliff
Edge a state-of-the-art hydrogen bomb a
100 times more powerful than the one
that destroyed Hiroshima the nose cone
dented but the bomb itself still
intact the Americans need to find it
first to get it away from this densely
populated Coastline and to stop the
Soviets from salvaging it for
themselves American ships and divers
scour the Spanish
Mediterranean looking for a lost
nuke they search miles of dark seabed
for almost 2
months but find
nothing you can imagine what it's like
feeling your way around there trying to
find an atomic
bomb then on March 15th
1966 a remotely controlled submersive
finally spot something when the
announcement came through I
[Music]
said the submersible attaches a rope but
as they carefully attempt to winch the
bomb to the
[Music]
surface the Rope suddenly
snaps
all the US Navy can do is wait for it to
hit the
bottom the fail safe system
holds and there's no chance of a
defination but a nuclear weapon full of
plutonium is lost once
again
Now using the latest data we can drain
the Mediterranean completely to reveal
where it
[Music]
falls a huge sea Canyon opens up nearly
3,000 ft
deep and right at the bottom the nuclear
bomb the difficult rescue attempt has
just become near impossible one of the
Air Force Colonels said if somebody had
sat down and thought about a way to lose
of a hydrogen bomb they couldn't have
thought of anything more
devilish finally the Navy sends a cable
controlled robot down into the canyon
and use it to grab the
nuke but it snags on the bomb's
parachute
it's now completely stuck half a mile
Under the
Sea the only way to retrieve the nuke is
to haul the robot up and drag the
parachute and bomb along with
it a delicate daisy chain for a 2ton
nuclear
weapon the man leading the mission
actually fainted from the
tension
miraculously the chain
holds these are two of the four
thermonuclear bombs dropped on
Spain on the left the nuke that
journeyed to the Bottom of the
Sea now safely stored in New
[Music]
Mexico to just see it lying there this
item contain the power to destroy a
city it's scary you
know a cold war catastrophe is
avoided but Operation Chrome doome is
suspended 2 years
[Music]
later nuclear confrontation has moved
beneath the
waves
200 miles off the coast of New
England draining the Waters of the
Atlantic exposes the horrors of a deep
sea
disaster by the
1960s the Cold War has a new front
line submarines armed with nuclear
weapons try to creep into enemy
Waters
America deploys hunter killer Subs to
guard against the
threat the very latest is the USS
Thresher powered by a nuclear
reactor on April 9th
1963 thresher sets out from Portsmouth
New Hampshire for sea trials
just over 200 miles
[Music]
out it begins triing extreme deep
waterer
Dives thresher was pushing boundaries
under the ocean The Men Who served on
her are very similar to um space
astronauts a US Navy ship called Skylar
is in attendance
a few hours into the trial the captain
of thresher sends out a call saying the
sub is experiencing minor
difficulties then fragments of a garbled
message a loud
hiss and
silence the staff aboard Skylark is not
quite sure what has happened and
continue to call to them and ask them to
respond they continue to do that for
some
period thresher never makes
contact and never
resurfaces Lori Areno is 8 years old
when the sub goes missing we were
watching TV and there was a news flash a
Navy ship was missing my brother went
running out into the kitchen by the time
I got there everyone was crying and I
didn't know why
but I just started crying and then
little by
little I found out that my dad was on
that
[Music]
boat in
1985 deep sea Explorer Dr Bob Ballard
sets out to find the wreck of the
[Music]
Titanic but his famous Expedition is a
cold war cover story in fact Ballard is
on a top secret mission to investigate
the wreck of the USS
[Music]
Thresher I was a trained Naval
intelligence officer the Soviets could
track me with
selling so we needed a cover
Ballard deploys a submersible equipped
with video
cameras the once classified
footage shows images of jagged
metal Ballard's first glimpse of what's
left of of the Lost
submarine the only way to understand the
scale of the
wreck is to see it in the light of
day A traumatic
scene the sub is ripped into mangled
pieces and Scattered across the seafloor
water drips off a torn Rudder and lying
behind it the conning tower on its
side there's a blasted Air
Canister and finally fragments of
piping little else is
identifiable so what we're seeing here
is the debris field of the thresher but
it's completely shredded this is
Carnage the only big piece was a piece
of the tail and even that looked like a
giant hand and just crushed it so it was
everywhere how did the USS Thresher end
up like
this it wasn't carrying
[Music]
Munitions its nuclear reactor isn't
explosive and there's no evidence of a
Soviet
attack Ballard believes that only a
force of nature can explain the
damage pressure is a deadly force so we
have a lot of experience with things
really blowing
up if a sub goes too deep the pressure
of the ocean becomes
overwhelming the whole structure will
suddenly fail
and
implode an implosion is a gigantic
explosion it's known as Crush
depth but why would the thresher be so
deep Ballard searches the wreck looking
for
[Music]
clues in the vast field of scattered
wreckage
bent pieces of piping litter the
seafloor some of these pipes would have
carried water into the sub from the sea
outside to cool the
reactor and during deep Dives they
become highly
pressurized Ballard knows a leak from
any of these pipes could trigger a
shutdown in the nuclear
reactor
when it comes in it comes in like a
jet and it can atomize in form of cloud
so it's just really coming in when that
happens the nuclear reactor
automatically
scrams he digs back into US Navy
files and uncovers a survey of the
thresher cooling
pipes the report reveals that some of
the pipe joints are weak and fail
testing
the message from thresher about
difficulties now makes
sense at 2200 ft below the sub Springs a
super high pressure
leak it makes a really nasty noise
sounds really high pitched it would just
go through You Like a
Knife the reactor power cuts
out the sub begins to fill with water
they can't drive out they're dead in
water but thresher should still
survive studying the wreck Ballard can
see components of a crucial buoyancy
system compressed air
canisters if the sub needs to surface
the canisters blow into ballast Chambers
and the buoyancy propels it
upwards
so why didn't the thresher do
that the US Navy conducts an
investigation what they find is
chilling in the cold conditions of the
thresher deep sea
dive moisture in the compressed air
freezes and blocks the
ballast so it froze over they couldn't
blow the hiss in the captain's final
message is the crew trying and failing
to blow the
ballast the shocking Discovery completes
the story of the last moments of the USS
Thresher at the bottom of its Deep dive
a powerful leak kills the engines and
the icy deep freezes and blocks the
ballast
pipes without power and
buoyancy and partially full of seawater
the thresher is dragged deeper and
[Music]
deeper and they are now taking on water
exceeding Cloud Stone they have no way
on the hull creaks and groans
the crew knows they are reaching Crush
depth they're just going down they're
getting deeper and they're crushing and
that is a tough way to die because
there's just nothing you can do at 2400
ft
below the pressure is 70 times greater
than at the
surface and when that went it just just
destroy the
sub it'll just crush you like you're not
even
there from above the full terrifying
power of that Monumental implosion is
clear the wreck has been blasted across
four square miles of
[Music]
ocean the first time I ever saw the
pictures of the wreck it was a profound
and Powerful experience the cold oldold
war was not a war without
[Music]
casualties Americans are not the only
ones to lose their lives beneath the
wild waters of the Northern Pacific lie
the remains of another
submarine how does a Soviet wonder
weapon fall victim to Cold War power
games
on February 24th
1968 a Soviet submarine leaves port in
Eastern Russia k9's mission is to
disappear beneath the waters off
America's West Coast armed with three
state-of-the-art nuclear missiles that
can launch from
underwater once fired the nukes are
almost
Unstoppable each one 65 times more
powerful than the hirosima bomb the
ocean itself has become
weaponized it is the ultimate cloak in
which you can hide and wait and then
deliver death the whole aura about the
nuclear submarines is to disappear from
the radar of the opposite
side two weeks into its Patrol in the
North Pacific k129 misses a scheduled
transmission
home something has gone badly
[Music]
wrong a Soviet navy flotilla scours the
Pacific looking for
k129 but it could be anywhere in a
thousand M sector of deep
ocean I mean it's beyond needle in a
Hast stack it's like needle in a
thousand haast stacks there was a
submarine out there that had been sunk
and the Russians had lost it literally
lost a
submarine after months of searching the
Soviets are forced to accept that their
submarine and their nuclear
weapons are lost so what does happen to
k129 today a new investigation is
uncovering a story of spycraft and
subterfuge journalist Josh Dean has
recently acquired images from a source
in America that show parts of the wreck
of the Lost Soviet
sub the remarkable black and white
pictures are hard to
decipher but using expert analysis to
enhance the
images means it's now possible to reveal
what remains of
k129 3 miles under the Pacific
Ocean the black steel of a coning
Tower and a fractured Silo still loaded
with a nuclear
missile only some sections of the sub
have ever been
identified and a clue as to
why lies here at the stern Jagged edges
of peeled back metal
The Telltale sign of a powerful internal
explosion this is an image I never
thought we'd be seeing
k129 it's heavily damaged whatever
forces were at play and I don't know if
we'll ever really know this is an
amazing and tragic
image it's hard to think of anything
more mysterious than
k129 it's a unprecedented
wreck searching for an explanation Dean
digs back into Cold War
history his research leads him to the
tropical shores of
[Music]
Hawaii in the
1960s this row of innocuous looking
buildings is a listening post for a top
secret us facil
called
sosus sosus is a vast network of
underwater
microphones that stretches across the
oceans of the
world listening for the sound of Soviet
submarines and tracking their
movement Marine Acoustics Professor
Bruce how has access to the Cold War
data the Russians were building
submarines that were coming
uncomfortably close to the United States
and so that motivated putting out these
listening
arrays in
1968 the Americans use acoustic
technology to try and find
k129 noticing the soviet's Frantic
search they scanned back over their data
looking for a
marker
and identify something far out in the
Pacific analysis suggests it could be an
underwater
[Music]
detonation have they found the sound of
the explosion that blasts k129 into
pieces sound can travel underwater
literally halfway around the world so in
the case of a submarine explosion that
would be a pretty obvious
signal if there was an explosion to this
day no one knows what caused it but by
triangulating the noise across the
network the US Navy can pinpoint where
the sound comes
from here 1 and a half th000 miles
Northwest of
Hawaii for the US Military a Soviet sub
loaded with nuclear missiles is a
Priceless
[Music]
Bounty but attempting to seize k129
would be an act of
War you can't just take stuff that
belongs to another military there was
real risk that going after this thing
could start a
war the US Navy closes the file and
leaves the wreck
untouched
but someone does tamper with k129 and
its nuclear missiles and the evidence is
in the
wreck some experts think that
k129 is probably destroyed by an
internal explosion deep under the
Pacific Ocean and there's evidence for
this theory on the drained wreck but
there's something else too signs that
something more than an explosion happens
here at the front there's no trace of
the jagged remains typically produced by
an explosion and the nose itself is
missing cleanly sliced
off how could that have
happened investigative journalist Josh
Dean is determined to find
out I think there are pieces of the k129
out there somewhere it's been lost for
some reason and lost is never
good Dean has been passed video shot in
1974 on board a ship called the glomar
[Music]
Explorer owned by eccentric American
billionaire Howard Hughes the glomar
claims to be a deep sea mining
[Music]
vessel but the video
reveals something straight out of a
James Bond
movie it's mindboggling it's remarkable
to see today that's footage that's never
been released
before hidden within the glomar Explorer
is a giant
cavity and a hydraulic
claw the men on board are CIA
operatives operation code name project
aoran
their mission is to recover sections of
k129 and especially its nuclear missiles
6 years after the sub went
down even most people within the CIA
were not aware of the existence of this
program the stakes could not be higher
essentially The Claw is designed to drop
down through 3 miles of ocean and
retrieve the sub and its nuclear
missiles
in the murky 45-year-old video it's
possible to see it down in the Deep
preparing to grasp a part of
[Music]
k129 it pulls a 2,000 ton section away
from the
seabed and begins an agonizing three-day
long Ascent to the
ship
two days into
winching on the
surface there's a sudden
jolt those Engineers who'd spent a lot
of time on boats thought like we
definitely just dropped some weight
something
happened stressed from digging into
seafloor one of the claws has cracked
open only the tip of the nose
remains most of what was in the claw
including the nuclear
missiles plunges back into the
darkness the guys on the ship have to
sit there and say we can't try again the
claw is
broken the CIA is forced to abandon the
[Music]
operation the dropped sub is still on
the floor of the Pacific today along
with its nuclear
weapons nobody knows how many more
Soviet Warheads are lost in our
oceans the US admits that six of its
nuclear weapons are
unrecovered left behind by a conflict
that abruptly ends in
1989 garbage off said we have tried to
kill your submarines we have failed we
quit the Soviet regime
[Applause]
collapses but the scars of the Cold War
remain beneath our
oceans nuclear weapons and radioactive
waste litter the
sea now the superpowers are
rearming with with thousands of new
missiles that can strike across the
globe secret nuclear power games
continue day and
[Music]
night